OK.
Here's an interesting voice mail.
Our number is two one nine two David P. with
a very interesting question about where are
all those?
Obama is going to declare martial law.
People right now.
Hey, David.
I just wanted to say and remember a few years
ago when Obama was president.
Yeah.
And he had all those.
Right.
When you're saying that he was going to declare
martial law and take away people's guns.
Yes.
Unleash the Blackhawk helicopters and all
that nonsense.
All right.
Well, where are those people now?
I don't get how they can see what's happening
now and not.
Against that.
Oh, I see how it was always partizan hackery.
They never really care about that stuff, that
it's very, very simple.
They're not complaining now about Trump because
when they see, oh, Trump is going to come
out and repress protests with the military,
they like it.
They like it was never about principles.
It was never about suspending habeas corpus
or whatever it was that they said it was just
partizan politics.
And it's being very boldly exposed right now.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about bicycle's becoming the
new toilet paper.
They are flying off the shelves during the
Corona virus pandemic.
And much more.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member.
At Join Pacman dot com.
And remember, every day the David Pakman show
audio podcast is available.
Get it on Spotify, Stitcher, Google Play podcast
I, iTunes, wherever you want.
Don't miss the podcast and we will see you
on the bonus ship.